excusez moi monsieur non vous de vous
nommer n'auriez vous pas
l'idée du duo miette des mig bank et le
petit parti d'abbas attention du à 3 c
ça fait trois jours c'est trois secondes
plus tard je m'en foutais rejeté par
aline odot d'avoir lé petit peu mais
c'est parfait pour pleurer les effets
pour toucher sa vocation salhiya
l'épidémie
tu grandiras jamais tu sais qui c'est
pas trop tôt pour en dire la famille
s'agrandira mais n'agit pas d'ici
il y aura dix rafale a dû les vidéos de
panneaux du grandir après tu dois dire à
l'un d'entre eux devra s'intégrer à la
menthe un jour un jour durera 18 mois
est d'y voir la plage de ta première
barboteuse on va t'acheter un peu fâché
par vote ça il faut il faut quelques
baffes de l'usaf
le vétéran d'irak ils rendirent
rajoutera draps deux ordres à fort 5 ans
tu seras tu va déjà voir ridicule dans
un bar de 2
3 qui rajoutera huit ans devant 15 ans
15 ans l'âge
l'ajout de l'âge les sens s'éveillent
va pas besoin de se faire qu'en temps
quand on a 15 ans et que tu iras de
l'étoile à la république tchèque ou
trois viennent lui passe par la concorde
est vite moi la madeleine quand tu fais
il faut y voir des toiles il fait la
diff érents l'étoile paraguay est là
alors hélas adroitement lier t'es pas là
on les sports sont en vigueur et en
dépit de la république
comme quoi quand on arrive à la concorde
tu me prends à la réponse à vos héros
dont je vais rentrer aux puits durant
d'irak hydrolien la famille qui s'est
agrandie rails un jour tu auras fait et
un an tu reviens sur l'habilité à 21 ans
ce qui permettra d'en être avoir 2 chez
le détachement
de quoi tu grandiras virtua ajoutera
fera trente ans quand d'identite mariera
en deux ans et pouvant être femme
charmant comme ça ma mort ja oui je sais
on peut trouver mieux en fait puis tu
m'en diras tu grandiras plus grand des
rails un jour durant 76 ans tu te
laissera les sports ferrand comme le 4
la pop
le rugby à 15 pour d'autres jeux de
tonnage double échec
le rugby à xiii
puis tu grandiras du grand handicap
on dirait un jour tu roi 94 ans
d'efforts tu seras là c'est comme si tu
es là c'est des chaussures soit connu
des ratés des chaussures il le connaît
déjà
il le connaît les arguments plus de
grandir à grandir avant d'enter grandir
a toujours essayé un jour il t'arrive
aide le plus grandir et qui ne se
révolte pas non acceptent d'autres ont
connu cela est qu'au jour ou la nuit se
fera dans la lumière des ténèbres de tes
yeux tu fera grandir estime que sera
laissée ici bas et se rappelant la part
apple anciennes l'accord avait lancé du
fer qui a tenu le fort et qui lui dit va
la vie et d'un appareil à la parabole
anciennes qui ont offert leur est alors
et 10 jeux parce que on au canada les
ventes vous avez les
les galas diez parce qu'en disent être
mangés par les louves départ et bien
c'est le voeu c'est le canadien n'est
pas bon tellement il ya c'est pas
tellement bon le canal hier à cause
beauvau relou les blues n'ont aucun
rapport alors moi je suis à mes jeux
je te le dis ça s'entend bien tous
petits diana le et à leur vie à leur ai
fait la part belle à vienne le 10 10 le
grand comme la première
combien vendée où j'adore la parabole
aider le vent n'est pas non écoute bien
ne mêle pas tout parce qu'autrement
alors c'est très bien et le berger
dis-je une biche je voulais avant ma vie
j'allais venir vous l'aborder et du
combat l'abordez vous baignez vous
l'avoir ça va t'il une fois homme et
qu'il avait le droit et où la foule
avait pas de place et laissait pas de
place